I can only begin to imagine how
difficult this must have been the impact
statements the the witness of the victim
personal statements that you gave in
court were absolutely heartbreaking
what's your reaction now that sentence
has been passed
um it doesn't matter how long the
sentence is or it's never going to be
enough
um you know it seems I think um the
justice system does need to introduce
tougher sentences because to me I mean
okay there were 16 at the time and these
took that into consideration their age
but to me I think the sentencing I've
seen the legal system needs to change
because life crime is just an epidemic
in this country and it's going to
continue and the deterrence are not
there you know the sentences need to be
tougher the law needs to get tougher and
just in general I think we need to do
something in this country to tackle
knife crime because it's a massive
massive problem
I mean we shocks when you found out how
easily these appalling weapons had been
purchased definitely definitely I mean
it's just ridiculous bit of pocket money
and then you know you could get yourself
a um a weapon and these people were you
know buying these weapons
um you know aliases you know other names
you know parents whatever and it's so
easy for them to get and the worst thing
was when this
um
when he went to collect his weapon on
that day he wasn't even that's for ideal
I think he just went there got his own
package and just walked out and I'm just
I'm thinking how easy it is you know we
heard from your victim personal
statements earlier how this has affected
you this has been devastating for the
family I mean how do you even begin to
try and cope does this sentence today
help you move on at all because
obviously they've got a sentence but
we've got a death sentence about a life
sentence sorry we're never going to
recover from this you know it's it's the
fact it's gonna affect us for the rest
of our lives you know and we can't
recover from this we've lost our
innocent boy and for what and for
nothing it's just ridiculous
appreciate if I couldn't talk to you now
I know this is such a difficult day for
you you were so brave giving that victim
statement earlier on today spoke so
passionately about your beautiful young
boy that you will miss so much
how do you feel now can this help you
move on now that the legal part of this
tragic event is is finished there's no
moving on from this not for a mother I
will always miss my child I will always
think how what happened to him how it
happened him how easily they obtain
these swords and what they did with this
brutality I would always always have to
live without not just this will
this is not a Justice to me 16 years for
a murder of a 16 year old by 16 year old
children
this is not good enough it is not good
enough by the law I do think yes we do
need to do something much more stronger
much more bigger for in order to stop
this nonsense because youth crime is
everywhere is it's everywhere recently
and I'm sick I'm sick of listening it
I'm sick of listening other mother
losing their children as well we're
becoming a bigger Community who are
losing their children for no reason
because of the knife crime
and my son did nothing wrong he was just
walking he was just coming he was two
doors away from his house
and we miss him so much I don't know how
far I can live past this grief but I
miss my boy so much
he's a lost your your brother you spoke
of him as being the glue that held the
family together you called for justice
inside the courtroom today have you got
Justice
um no we have not got Justice
unfortunately we'll never get Justice
the way they easily you know acquire
these knives and murdered my only
brother will never get Justice
unfortunately however we are campaigning
for her shallows on against knife crime
we are arranging marches you know this
is our campaign we want to tell
everybody what a beautiful beautiful boy
Ron and Kanda was and the way he's gone
it's not fair and unfortunately I can't
see Ronan being the last child to go
like this he's he from my brother Ronan
Kanda is the most beautifulest boy there
is on this planet
it's amazing we are doing the march on
the 19th of July
and against a knife crime and we are
gonna the starting point is where they
took ronan's life yes so if anybody out
there would like to join us please do so
I this mother would like to like your
help
in making this much a successful against
the knife crime